come on it's obviously could be a little
bit John Jones because not John Doe said
it once he said it one he did not he
said it was quite Tony Tony Ferguson you
know and I think what's up guys how are
you doing in Chicago a town with our
friend
I'm the Dean show Ben Askren we'll be
right back Ben Askren and you can watch
him on the Dean show I bought that tuna
to the Dean show
so Ben tell us Olympic wrestler former
Olympic wrestler also world champion and
MMA what else keeps you busy though I'm
so bad I got three kids we have through
wrestling ki atomies we have a camp
system I work at the badge rdc and I
have three podcasts I think that's
everything I do so pretty busy
what's your breakdown in the fight Tony
was it Tony Ferguson yeah and cowboy I
think it's gonna be a bloodbath but I
think it would also see that any
differently I don't really expect you to
want him to have a huge grappling
advantage so I think it's gonna come
down to the striking and both of our
similar right they're not power strikers
they both have high outputs and they
also have more often than they have
defense so may III feel like it's gonna
be Ferguson but if it's Cerrone I'm not
really surprised at all how about the
Olympian Henry versus the Brazilian yeah
I'm cheering for Henry cuz I know from
wrestling but I also know that's a
really really tough fight for him Marlin
is very good on his feet and so I think
it's gonna be Ken Henry get the takedown
in control top position or is marlowe
I'm gonna keep it on his feet
and then if he does keep it there can be
effective with this kickboxing I'm gonna
throw a few words at you and how do you
how do you deal with it because you're
also someone who's a teacher as far as
wrestling coach and whatnot ego
how do you deal with the ego or teaching
your students dealing with the ego
because it could be a detriment what do
you have to say about ego man I you know
I think it's I think everything has two
sides right you got to have a balance I
want kids to want to care about how they
do and the results and how they look in
that stuff but obviously then if you you
know one great example of if you care
about it too much to admit your weakness
or admit your faults then your egos
gonna kill you because you're not
willing to admit those things that are
holding you back from reaching the next
level and so I think without any quality
I think there's a balance between the
good and the bad of that quality so you
know ego you got to be able to lecture
you go to admit hey I need to do better
at my single-leg or I need to be at
practice more often or whatever it is
that's holding you back
what about effort we hear you speaking a
lot about effort yeah well I think
effort is the only thing that you can
truly control in life and so when I when
I talk about my athletes I asked I tell
them hey that that's literally the only
thing that you can control and so
control that for me if you give if you
give me great effort today that's all I
expect out of you and whether the
resulting outcome is positive or
negative where I'm gonna I'm gonna be
happy with you and then if we just keep
doing that great effort day after day
year after year good results are gonna
happen bullying is the skyrocketing
thing man just you know so much bullying
going on how do you do it you address
some of these things and what kind of
things pointers do you give to kids you
got to try to combat yeah the growing
epidemic of bullying it's the time you
know the parents you know that's where
it starts or the bullish side so to say
parents sometimes the bully is not born
the bullies created where it is you know
I don't know I think we're lucky like I
don't see a lot of that in my academy
and I don't know if that's because I
treat the kids well and the other
coaches treat the kids well and they
don't see that coming from the top they
don't do it to each other but all of our
kids get along pretty well with it the
older kids the young kids we don't see
we don't see a huge amount of bullying
so it hasn't been an addition in an
issue we better address a lot with Ozzie
obviously I do address it a couple times
but usually once people get in there and
they they they feel the environment we
too often I think maybe you know I think
maybe it's about I always talk about
teaching kids with love and caring you
know that they know that we're there and
we care about them and we want them to
be better and they feel that and they
don't do the goal yet how about kids
coming up with drugs so many of the
other vices there yeah how you keep them
focused on the sport and not to fall
into many of these pitchers I think one
of the our main focuses from from day
one was to get people to love the sport
of wrestling and once we can do that
everything else takes care of something
I've set it up to I said well if you if
you love something you care about it
you're more often more likely to show up
really often right so your your work
ethics to me better your disciplines to
me better and so I think that's Lucy has
a lot of kids they actually really I'm
not forcing to want to be good wrestling
they want to be good at wrestling and
when they want to be good wrestling they
do their academics all day they take
care of their social life and so when we
can get them to care about being good at
something and they realize you're having
a negative social life is gonna hurt
them I think they spend a lot of time
staying away from that type of stuff I'm
gonna give you a quiz now oh and then a
reaction okay which one let's do the
country could spare who's the fighter
now go for a B and C who says phrase
after each one of his fights
he says the phrase and then what does it
mean you ready sure the phrases and hum
didn't last is this Conor McGregor a B
John Jones
see hobby come on it's obviously could
be a little bit John Jones because not
John Jones said it once he said it one
he did not he said it wasn't I'm good
sir how you doing oh man
that is so good alhamdulillah he said it
it's now so you got with me you got the
first part so you got fifty okay so what
does it mean now I always say it more
time huh say one more time
alhamdulillah and he is saying al
hamdulillah al hamdulillah
everything's God gave me so again he's
keeping it humble if anything we could
take away from his video is is is that
quality of keeping it humble we got too
much we're all susceptible to an ego the
ego can take over and you become very
arrogant who likes to be around arrogant
people keeping it humble again he's
saying alhamdulillah it just like saying
thank you God everything God gave me
very simple now you're gonna preach can
you appreciate that let's go on to the
next thing I'll make it even easier
probably all power to him or I know he's
very religious so he's probably giving
it all I'll make it easier ok hallelujah
hallelujah praise Jesus
I guess oh praise the Creator God busy
crazy Pharaoh it's time did a lot equals
I try not to take sides yeah everybody
look for everybody so it's more of a
like praising the creator of the heavens
and earth God Almighty so we got that
and then let's do one reactions ok video
ok this would be one minute of watch and
then want to get your reaction if just
whatever comes from your heart your mind
whatever feeling and we'll go from there
you spent a lot of time in
I spent some time some time warden
Singapore how because you're you've
gotten to travel a lot yeah did that
open your mind and how did you feel
traveling done did did for you as a
human being as a person getting out you
know out of your comfort zone the
traveler well I was a geography major so
I always kinda I felt like I was
well-rounded I kind of knew
that makes everything was won by me one
is
[Music]
Davina Monty all become imagine
well
[Music]
everything No
I said told us the owners
really cool
[Music]
no banker who are on iMovie
once anyone me
[Music]
we just saw him talking about moral
value and character and airport
yeah I don't know prior to listen to
more to get more of a reaction okay so I
like what you said just getting to a
whole nother level of morality of
character yeah I can never lose with
that where you mentioned love for
everybody being a good noble character
absolutely that stuff's so important
yeah so do we teach our kids to
wrestling you teach your kids through to
Jitsu it man so everybody pushing their
kids right morals values in character my
brother here van Askren I'm the deso all
right so you guys are probably wondering
might white male keeps wearing this
shirt he has like a hundred copies of
the show right no 100 but how many he
has a lot as what a few quite a few so
he's not wearing the exact same shirt
okay I don't want people to think that
you're wearing the same shirt all the
time every so every picture see he goes
from the highest point to the lowest
just humbling himself you know keeping
it humble because a lot of times some of
you get to make a lot of money a lot of
fame and you become arrogant you go
haughty so the idea with salah the
prayer right here as you're seeing so
that prayer just humbling yourself
keeping a humble putting your forehead
on the ground many people meditate it's
kind of form of meditation but at a
whole nother level keep it at humble
thanking the one who created us giving
all these blessings the one guy the same
guy that Jesus Moses Abraham prayed to
testify was praying to the last
muhammad peace be upon him peace be with
you so I'm making